michael deux groupes est l'un des hommes
d'affaires les plus riches au canada
mais après avoir misé une fortune dans
l'industrie des casinos caraïbes
il s'est retrouvé au coeur d'un violent
conflit impliquant plusieurs individus
louches
deux frères au passé trouble alors dans
l'enveloppé la lettre disait voici cinq
balles on va en mettre cinq autres dans
ta tête et dans la tête de ton frère qui
est un influent parrain de la mafia vie
touristes au high tech s'emballer il
serait temps que quelqu'un dise à mike
les choses comme elles sont
félicitations tu couches avec la mafia
maintenant
fins de mois alors que le milliardaire
est enregistrée à son insu ses associés
commence à parler d'assassinât
[Musique]
michael de groot voyage à bord de son
jet privé
bombardier global express début 2011 il
s'apprête à atterrir en république
dominicaine après plusieurs réussites
commerciales éclatante au canada et à
l'étranger
l'homme d'affaires cherche de nouveaux
défis il va bientôt lancer une
entreprise risquée et audacieuse par
l'industrie des casinos avec deux
torontois les frères francesco et
antonion carbone et je peux vraiment
dire qu'au tout début
michael de groot était comme un second
père pour moi en fait on pouvait se
parler deux trois quatre fois par jour
j'écoutais tout ce qu'il me disait et ça
restait bien gravé dans mon esprit
au début de leur collaboration les deux
frères ont voyagé à bord du jet privé de
michael de gut s'est montré un autre les
plus courtois
c'était fantastique le grand confort
service de bar il y avait même lit il
m'a dit frenck si tu veux faire une
sieste
j'ai fait préparer mon lit pour ça j'ai
répondu non non ça ira
la république dominicaine semblait très
ouverte aux nouvelles opportunités
d'affaires avec son industrie
touristique en déclin son chômage élevé
et un gouvernement très peu porté sur la
réglementation
[Musique]
jouer et parier a toujours été une
activité de prédilection dans ce pays
le samedi soir au ring de combat de coqs
on peut même place et s'établit par
carte de crédit les coqs se battre
jusqu'à la mort des lames de rasoir fixé
aux pattes
[Musique]
même accueil de groupes que les frères
carbone et voit plus grand leur plan est
d'acheter les plus gros casino de lille
de les soumettre aux exigences légales
du moment pour créer un las vegas des
caraïbes une gigantesque planche à
billets les frères carbonées avait déjà
créé une machine à jouer électronique
qui avait impressionné
mc de goult à toronto ils étaient très
impatients de se lancer dans le projet
parce qu'il savait flairé une bonne
affaire en temps de crise où d'abondance
les gens aiment jouer tout le monde jour
le parcours personnel de michael de
groupes faciles défaire carbonée la
vidéo de sa biographie qui s'est fait
produire raconte l'histoire d'un homme
qui bâtit sa fortune à partir de rien sa
famille quitte la belgique pour le
canada au lendemain de la seconde guerre
mondiale michael quitte l'école à 14 ans
pour travailler à la ferme de tabac de
ses parents
[Musique]
il gagne son premier million puis le
père avant ses 29 ans en 1959 il fait
l'acquisition de l'est de la une
entreprise de camionnage plus tard de
groot se lance dans la collecte des
déchets où il fera fortune il devient
propriétaire des tiger cats d'hamilton
pendant cinq ans durant les années 70
mais sa carrière n'est pas sans tache
lui et d'autres personnes nous associer
à la bande les deux là ont dû débourser
23 millions de dollars pour régler à
l'amiable des accusations sans toutefois
admettre leur culpabilité
pour échapper à l'impôt il prend sa
retraite aux bermudes dans un immense
domaine sur le bord de mer mais il
s'ennuie très vite et se remet aux
affaires il acquiert une importante
participation dans la chaîne blockbuster
auprès de son propriétaire
il est aussi honoré par l'université
mcmaster à hamilton
l'institution donne son nom à des
pavillons
après avoir fait un des plus gros don de
toute l'histoire universitaire au pays
mais en 2011 il concentre sur tous ses
efforts sur l'accroissement de sa
fortune en tenue carbonées prétend que
l'entente des casinos a été conclu sur
deux crimes
le luxueux ya 270 pied de mât que de
groot carbon et dit qu'il a été très
impressionné par tout ce qu'il a
découvert à bord
souillac était un hôtel cinq étoiles sam
hd parterre de voir tout ça elle
m'aurait fallu deux paires d'yeux pour
absorber tout ce qu'il y avait là une
énorme salle de séjour salle à manger
cuisine un écran de télévision géant
c'est le genre de chose qu'un gars comme
moi aurait juste pu voir au cinéma
après négociation l'entente finale
prévoyait que les frères carbonées
posséderait 85% des actions de la
nouvelle compagnie rim casino
michael de groot aurez droit à une part
des profits mais spécifiait qu'il
n'était que créancier
donc même en versant des millions dans
l'entreprise de gluck n'aurait pas
d'autres responsabilités qui voulait
dire qu'il ne serait pas un partenaire
mais un investisseur cela n'avait pas
d'impact sur moi je n'avais pas besoin
d'en parler vous exigez secret pas de
problème je ne dirai rien n' ajouté jack
le vieil ami de mcdo croûte est alors
nommé à la présidence d'accompagner ces
pays jack qui avait présenté les carboni
à michael de groot
la raison derrière cette nomination
c'est que selon eux le pejak présentait
une image de président directeur général
plus raffinés comparativement à mon
frère et moi
je
l'industrie du jeu a mauvaise réputation
dans les caraïbes elle traîne un longue
historique d'infiltration par la mafia
durant des décennies c'est à travers des
casinos ont blanchi c'est l'argent
généré par la drogue et la prostitution
de plus l'écart et b tel endroit par où
la drogue de riches transitaient vers le
nord les frères carbonées parle alors
d'un plan pour nettoyer les casinos
dominicain loin dans le passé
la république dominicaine présentait
encore le portrait où le crime organisé
dirigé les casinos c'était aussi comme
ça à las vegas avant mais les grandes
compagnies s'y sont impliqués et ont
tout nettoyé
c'est ce qu'on est venu faire en
république dominicaine on a racheté
chaque endroit et on a tous transformés
comme les gens de vegas mais les carboni
leurs associés paix jack et elle a ses
propres pour nettoyer michael de groot
regrette peut-être d'avoir si peu
vérifier les antécédents de suez qui
traitait tout cet argent
les frères carboni possédait une
compagnie fabricant est important des
cigares et cigarillos sous la marque
donne carbonées en décembre 2009
l'entreprise s'effondre après une
perquisition au siège social de toronto
dans le cadre d'une enquête pour évasion
fiscale
on avait trouvé deux révolvers non
enregistrés l'un dans la filière
d'antonio et l'autre chargé et au numéro
de cirilli mais sous le bureau
defrancesco les frères carbonées 10 et
subissaient des menaces de mort j'étais
au bureau et j'ouvrais mon courrier dans
l' enveloppe la lettre disait voici cinq
mâles et on va en mettre cinq autres
dans ta tête et dans la tête de ton
frère cinglé ou même plusieurs singles i
qui veulent nous loger cinq balles dans
la tête
malheureusement nous avons pris la
décision d'acheter des armes à feu pour
assurer notre sécurité
c'était une précaution qu'on a prises
pour protéger nos familles et nous mêmes
on dirait que vous voulez nous
convaincre que c'était une bonne idée
avec le recul vous ne trouvez pas que
c'est tout le contraire soulim ans
c'était une idée épouvantable mais votre
question est pourquoi vous avez fait ça
alors je vous explique qu'elle a été
notre réaction
les frères carbonées ont passé 60 jours
en prison pour possession illégale
d'armes
selon eux cette condamnation n'était pas
ma col de gucht
non pas du tout il venait ici
accompagnés de gardes armés
pas d'inquiétude les armes à feu ne le
rendait absolument pas nerveux pas du
tout
des faits indique qu'elle n'est pas
convaincu le groupe s'est associé avec
les frères gabonais
ceux-ci s'impliquait dans platinum
sportsbook une compagnie de jeux sur
internet
il nie tout la police publiera des
informations classant la mafia et les
ardennes jose à la tête de platinum
malgré ce passé douteux drink
corporation la nouvelle compagnie des
frères carbone et voit le jour en 2011
en république dominicaine
michael de groot leur prêtent plus de 10
millions de dollars pour leur premier
achat de casino partout au pays
en peu de temps la compagnie emploie
5000 personnes et pèse 2 millions de
dollars pour un avis aura que 800
flambant neuf pour des déplacements des
frères carbonée
au cours de l'hiver et du printemps 2012
mcl de groot continue d'injecter de
l'argent pour l'achat et la rénovation
d'installations de jeu une somme de 112
millions de dollars
selon michael de cloud les choses se
seraient envenimées en septembre 2012
avec les premières rumeurs voulant que
les deux frères l'escroc qu'est le
groupe prétend avoir appliqué sur
facture est l'achat et la rénovation des
casinos et empocher des pots-de-vins il
a dit en cour
on m'a dit que les carbone et ne volais
qu'ils empochent une partie des profits
et gonfler les factures ou passage il
prétend que les deux frères se sont
dérobés et n'ont rien fait il a exigé de
voir des rapports financiers de la
compagnie
les dossiers présentés à la cour font
état de faits troublants
il y a une grosse différence entre les
rapports mensuels et le genre
d'information que demandait monsieur de
cloot sans en avoir le droit
à la fin janvier 2014
un des rapports judiciaire indique que
sur les 49 millions de dollars prêtés
par de good pour l'achat et la
rénovation de casino près de 22 millions
dans laissé aucune trace
j'ai commencé à avoir de sérieux doutes
à propos de leur honnêteté et de leur
intégrité piccione coeur a été
consultant ou tout début de green corps
pression lui aussi a un passé trouble ex
procureure de la couronne sont permis
d'exercer le droit a été révoqué en 2008
à la suite de sa condamnation pour
blanchiment d'argent
je n'ai que dix en être arrivé à la
conclusion que les carbonées escroquait
jeu devenait de plus en plus inquiet en
les voyant utiliser certains stratagèmes
par rapport à mike
alors je suis entré en contact avec lui
je lui dis je travaille avec les frères
carbonées et je n'aime pas du tout ce à
quoi j'assiste mike je suis vraiment
inquiet il m'a répondu que ça l'inquiète
est lui aussi un drop et jack l'ami de
de groot et président de l'uimm casino
est lui aussi furieux il dit ce qu'il
pense des femmes carbonées lors d'une
des conversations enregistrées en secret
qui ont été soumises en cours par les
carboni
kitchen de secours
[Musique]
il se trouve qu'un jour p jack a lui
aussi un passé douteux dans les années
80 il était impliqué dans une enquête
d'une compagnie d'enlèvement d'ordures
qui sera décrite en cours comme une
entreprise aux activités banian
totalement dans la criminalité
plusieurs personnes impliquées dans ce
dossier disque pays jack se vantait
souvent de ses contacts au sein de la
mafia
lors d'une conversation enregistrée
bjack prétend avoir blanchi l'argent de
la mafia
après la pause
michael du groupe et en groupe et jack
décide d'entrer en guerre contre les
frères carbonée
d michael j de groot signeurs score
kamako de groot apparaissent en public
c'est presque toujours pour faire des
dons avec de larges sommes accordées à
des collèges et universités
le 10 mai 2013
une réunion secrète a lieu dans la suite
de luxe de la famille du groupe
surplombant la ville au ritz-carlton de
toronto le milliardaire y met de l'avant
une toute autre facette de lui même en
quête d'alliés dans sa guerre contre les
carbone et le prestigieux magna
rencontre de leurs anciens partenaires
le premier pitch and girls qui a décidé
d'épauler de groot dans son combat quant
à l'autre on le lui présente comme étant
sa xavi sert maison qu'à chaque goutte
qu'il a un dossier criminel très chargé
et qu'il est sorti de prison il ya moins
d'un an
sacha viscères utilisent d'autres
identités
pavlik hollidge comme on le voit sur ce
passeport croate
ou encore sacha vujacic sur passeport
canadien
et enfin zelko zde reach sur un
passeport bosniaque au canada il a été
condamné et emprisonné pour plus de 40
crime dont fraude usurpation d'identité
ainsi que voies de fait et menaces de
mort ça xavi sert à enregistrer la
rencontre à l'insu des participants qui
discutaient de la façon de mettre les
faire carbonées hors d'état de nuire
et puis ça xavi sert enfin de groot de
s'occuper de tout en personne
[Musique]
il est aussi question d'acheter des
témoins après avoir refusé de goût de
fini par demander combien pour écouter
quelqu'un qui viendrait témoigner contre
les frères carbonées il négocier un
montant de cinq cent mille dollars
mais vers la fin de la rencontre ils se
remettent à hésiter et dit qu'il va
devoir obtenir l'avis de son avocate
piccione qui a aussi ses réserves mike
humain qu'a décrit tout ça comme un plan
pour acheter des témoins je m'en
souviens très bien
il m'a demandé si j'étais à l'aise avec
l'idée et j'ai dit que j'étais en total
désaccord
les trois hommes se donnent rendez-vous
dans la suite du rich le lendemain entre
temps de groot a été mise en garde par
son avocate
[Musique]
la rencontre se poursuit et on entend de
groot offrira sa xavi sert une avance en
attente dupes les montants à la
signature du contrat vers la fin la
rencontre prend une tournure inquiétante
de groot sans vouloir vérifier si le
sujet de la discussion
est bel et bien l'assassinât des frères
carbonées par l'entremise de son avocat
d'une joute affirme que ces
enregistrements visait à le manipuler et
sont le fait de gens passés maîtres dans
l'art de la duperie
dans son témoignage en cour de groot
affirme n'avoir en fin de compte jamais
donné d'argent à viscères
et qu'il avait refusé de l'engager il
reconnaît toutefois que blizzard a été
engagé par green corporation qu'il
faisait du bon travail en éteignant des
feux
[Musique]
pendant une certaine période sacha
viscères joue sur les deux tableaux
il a fourni d'abord au carbone et des
extraits des enregistrements du ritz
carlton
mais par ensuite travaillé pour de
grosses épées jack et complotent contre
les deux frères il envoie alors des
textos l'histoire nous enseigne qu'on
peut tuer n'importe qui les rameurs
quand on en tue deux d'un coup savez
normalement dire que le problème a été
réglé
et et 2013 sacha wisser débarque en
république dominicaine une caméra de
sécurité le montre au casino
d'entreprise à punta cana green
corporation à l'évêque lui octroyer une
procuration pour agir en son nom
il commence à menacer de mort un employé
de dream
il associe des messages de menace sur le
téléphone d'antonio carbonées ma
réaction
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je fasse à
part avertir la police c'est exactement
ce que j'ai fait l alerte générale on
est tout le temps aux aguets on regarde
tout autour de soi ont conduit les
enfants à l'école
on fait tout en son pouvoir pour
protéger la famille c'était la seule
chose à faire
qu'est ce que j'aurais pu faire d'autre
lorsque le président de l'uimm casino en
du pejak lancé lucie des menaces de mort
durant plusieurs jours il a répété qu'il
allait protéger son vieil ami max de
groot et ses ventes et de son projet de
pourchasser les carboni jeu
p jaxx t c'est enregistrements révèlent
la vraie nature de paix jet à 110% ce
dont il se vante il est prêt à le faire
est ce que c'est une menace c'est
certain est-ce qu'il était sérieux tout
à fait absolument je peux vous dire
exactement ce dont il est capable
pays jack est capable d'engager
quelqu'un pour vous assassiner sans
problème
le groupe et jack a aussi été
enregistrée en train de parler un
certain mike selon les avocats de de
blood on ne peut affirmer que c'est leur
client dans cet enregistrement pejak
fait allusion à un mystérieux nouveaux
joueurs
l'homme qui vient de l'autre promesse
[Musique]
c'est à cette période que l'on aperçoit
au casino le fameux parrain de la mafia
montréalaise vito rizzuto
[Musique]
la vidéo de la biographie de michael de
groot le montre en train de parcourir le
monde dans son jet privé de rencontrer
des souverains des présidents comme
george bush il a été décoré de l'ordre
du canada par le gouverneur général
il est donc plutôt troublant que son nom
soit associé aujourd'hui à celui d'une
légende du crime organisé en 2006 le
redoutable paraît montréalaise vito
rizzuto est extradé aux états unis afin
de subir son procès pour les meurtres de
trois mafieux
25 ans plus tôt il est condamné à une
peine de cinq ans et demi dans un
pénitencier américain pendant qu'il
purge sa peine
ses ennemis s'attaque à son clan tout
d'abord son fils est assassiné puis son
beau-frère disparaît et enfin son père
tombe sous les balles en octobre 2012
vito rizutto libéré et rentrer au canada
un caméraman de radio-canada montent à
bord du vol d'air canada pour filmer la
scène
dans les mois qui suivent le retour de
résultats au pays
13 meurtres reliés à la mafia sont
commis selon la police le parent se
venge et vu reconquérir son empire
brigitte au voyage alors beaucoup entre
le canada et la ligue 1 min cannes où il
s'est aussi été mise
depuis des années le clan rizzuto
trempait dans la contrebande de drogue
destinée au canada le voici en ou 2013
alors qu'une caméra de surveillance
capte sa visite au dream casino de punta
cana
il est accompagné du nouveau responsable
de la dream sacha viscères les frères
carbonées crois que vito rizzuto était
là pour les effrayer
quand on vient d'un milieu italien
on sait qui et vito rizutto on n'a
surtout pas besoin de google un an comme
vito rizutto ça va créer la peur chez
les gens ils ont donc fait venir pour
vous intimider tout à fait à 110% il
était là pour nous intimider
[Musique]
un incroyable chapitre de l'histoire de
dunes casino va se jouer à casa de campo
un quartier protégé et cossu de la
république dominicaine le parrain de la
mafia habito régis tôt il séjourne
depuis longtemps et tout porte à croire
qu'il a mis une maison voisine à la
disposition du nouveau responsable de
tous une casino de criminels sachent à
bissert au sujet de cette relation avec
vidéo le judo dont bénéficiait sa xavi
sert le principal intéressé s'est montré
fort peu loquace quand le réalisateur de
la bbc avec à chaud l'a abordée en
pleine rue
sacha bissert s'est montré très bien
septembre 2013
un groupe et jack le bon ami de mac de
groupe et président depuis le casino se
rend en république dominicaine sur un
vol privé
selon certaines sources il participe à
des rencontres avec sacha me sers et
vito rizzuto dans un restaurant italien
de casa de campo apparemment pour parler
de la possibilité d'une implication du
parrain de la mafia dans green casino
l'ex procureure de la couronne peter
schnittger dit avoir participé à
certains de ces rencontres dont une chez
vit tous riches d'eau de risque bien
mais on était là pour une rencontre un
dp jack était là et c'est devenu très
clair pour moi qu'il était un peu chez
lui ici
il avait ses quartiers dans une partie
de la maison
c'était comme ces appartements comme il
demeurait chez vitaux il était sans
doute à ses proches
en fait leur amitié semble exister
depuis assez longtemps
les rencontres avec vito rizzuto ont
duré plusieurs jours à casa de campo
piccione que raconte qu'il a été
stupéfait d'apprendre lors d'une
discussion que le paraît prendrait
bientôt une grande participation dans
green casino
je me rappelle que monsieur rizutto à
dire il faudrait bien faire approuver
tout ça par mc de groot et un dp jack a
répondu c'est moi le représentant de mag
de groot
quand j'ai reçu un appel de mac de groot
après cette discussion et il m'a dit
[ __ ] mais qu'est-ce que vito rizutto
vient faire dans ce projet j'ai répondu
c'est à ton amie paige à qu'il faut
demander ça
il doit marcher rizutto
après cette rencontre et jack s'envolent
rapidement pour le canada sur un vol
privé
la liste des passagers montre que deux
associés de résultats l'accompagnent le
2 jean pétrau tiberio va devenir sous
peu
représentant légal sherwin cooperation
quant à vito rizzuto il rentre au pays
en octobre 2013
apparemment avec l'intention d'entrer en
contact avec les frères carbonées et
négocier une trêve
une nouvelle entente lui permettant de
s'impliquer dans les casinos
après avoir invité des semaines durant
tout contact avec le parrain de la mafia
antonio carbone et raconte avoir été
sommé de se rendre à une rencontre avec
les tutos dans ce café de toronto jeudi
sommet parce qu'on m'a fait bien
comprendre que je ferais mieux de me
présenter sinon c'est à cause de ceux ci
n'ont que j'ai décidé de m'y rendre
il a dit je suis vito rizzuto vous savez
que je suis
on a bien mis en évidence qu'il était un
pilier du crime organisé
selon carbonée les négociations se sont
poursuivies en soirée lors d'un souper
offert par vito rizzuto dans une salle à
manger privée du hac a gangsta
californie au nord de toronto un groupe
et jack se joint à eux
et selon carbonées vito rizzuto a
présenté un plan très clair
ses intentions étaient vraiment très
simple il voulait se servir de twin pour
faire du blanchiment d'argent
j'ai répondu je suis désolé mais je ne
peux pas vous suivre là dedans mais je
ne vais pas non plus céder ma
participation d'andrine et si je dois
mourir à cause de ça tant pis et vous
êtes parti ouais saviez vous
l'impression que votre vie était menacée
absolument absolument à et même
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression qu'elle
est menacée et je vais sans doute
craindre d'être tué jusqu'à la fin de ma
vie
peu après le moment où antonio carbone
et d avoir rejeté l'offre de vito
rizzuto en décembre 2013
les choses ont pris une tournure
violente en république dominicaine
les employés fidèles aux frères k bonnet
et les membres du clan rizzuto en sont
venus aux coups pour se disputer le
contrôle du siège social de twin casino
peter chan que dit que ces événements
l'ont bouleversé et il pensait qu'il
fallait mettre en garde michael de groot
contre vito rizzuto
j'ai dit il serait temps que quelqu'un
dise à mike les choses comme elles sont
félicitations tu couches avec la mafia
maintenant et ça me frustrait beaucoup
que personne n'ose dire à mike ce qui se
passait parce que je sais que mike est
une bonne personne
cet homme là un bon jugement de
l'influencé qu'auraient pu avoir vito
rizzuto sur green casino est un sujet
qui restera un mystère à la fin décembre
2013 à montréal vito rizzuto est admis
d'urgence à l'hôpital il combattait un
cancer depuis des années
il meurt deux jours avant noël pour des
frères carbonées si vito rizzuto était
toujours en vie ils contrôleraient leur
compagnie et eux seraient morts vito
était encore en vie je ne sais pas si
vous pourriez faire cette entrevue
aujourd'hui comment réagit mcl de groot
à l'implication de vito rizzuto son
avocat répond monsieur de groot n'a
jamais rencontré monsieur résultats ne
lui a jamais parlé et n'a jamais été
associé avec lui d'aucune façon il
ajoute monsieur de groot ne s'est jamais
rendu complice d'une implication de
membres du crime organisé dans aucune de
ces entreprises
en décembre 2013 de nombreux signaux
d'alarmé indiquait déjà l'implication du
crime organisé dans l'une casino
pourtant michael de groot a continué d'y
injecter de l'argent 2,4 millions de
dollars durant les mois de janvier
février 2014
depuis un an le rêve étincelant de ma
clause de groot
avec tous ces casinos en république
dominicaine si bien obscurci de part et
d'autre il ya eu escalade dans les
affrontements violents en ou 2014 a fait
le castro mercedez un avocat d'une
casino a été retrouvé assassiné chez lui
le crime pourrait être lié à son
implication dans les casinos dans un
enregistrement on entend l'ex avocat
peter schoenacker dire que le meurtrier
a voulu lancer un avertissement
il doit apprendre la leçon laissé par le
cas de castro des gens sont prêt à tout
quand on les emmerde trop en fait ce que
j'ai voulu dire c'est que la république
dominicaine et comme le far west
les gens ont recours à la violence
beaucoup plus rapidement qu'on ne le
fait au canada et de toute évidence
monsieur castro avait rendu quelqu'un
vraiment très en colère très en colère
parce que c'était plus qu'un meurtre
ordinaire c'était une boucherie
en république dominicaine lempire de
dream casino est en lambeaux plusieurs
employés sont en lock out et se
plaignent de s'être fait voler leur
salaire la direction est sous la
protection de gardes armés
sacha bissert s'est vu retirer la
procuration qu'il exerçait au nom de
dream casino il est à présent criminels
en fuite ayant quitté le canada alors
que les accusations pesant contre lui
dans ses déclarations sous serment
michael de groot a reconnu que faire
affaire avec les criminels sachent
viscères avait été une grave erreur
il a dit j'aimerais juste savoir où est
mon argent et avec la chance pouvoir de
récupérer un groupe et jacky lui aussi
poursuivi par son vieil ami mike de
'brut' nous l'avons un tracé à toronto
dans l'ascenseur d'une tours
d'appartements
il n'a rien voulu dire
quant aux frères carbonée il se bat pour
garder le contrôle de leurs casinos mais
une série de jugements et de rapports de
séquestre judiciaire relève plusieurs
irrégularités financières dans leur
gestion de l'entreprise
un juge note qu'un énorme montant
d'argent semble avoir été mal dépensé un
autre écrit ma queue de groupe bénéficie
à première vue d'une très forte preuves
de fraudes contre les frères carbone
était une preuve de fraude
à première vue qu'est-ce que ça peut
bien vouloir dire pour de vulgaires
profanes comme mon frère et moi ou bien
il y as fraude ou bien il n'ya pas
fraude ou bien je suis coupable de
meurtre où je ne suis pas coupable de
meurtre donc jouir s vous ne vous rendez
pas compte que beaucoup de citoyens vont
lire les chiffres de ces rapports et les
nombreux jugements et simplement
conclure que vous avez escroqué michael
de groot ne lui pas samedi ça est ce que
s'est dit ça par rapport
ça ne dis pas que j'ai volé de l'argent
à quel endroit du rapport
je mets au défi qui que ce soit de
fournir une preuve que j'ai volé quelque
argent que ce soit ou de révéler des
comptes bancaires que j'aurais tenu
secret quelque part dans le monde ou
bien des actifs que je n'aurais pas
déclarer quelque part dans le monde et
qui ne sont pas le fruit de mon travail
ou 2013 un dernier rebondissement dans
l'histoire de green casino
la police de toronto dépose une plainte
au criminel contre francesco carbon les
ils l'accusent d'avoir comploté causé la
mort d'un groupe et jack l'accusation
repose sur un enregistrement de sa voix
[Musique]
je serai parfaitement honnête je ne dis
absolument rien dans l'enregistrement
il ya eu du montage et des coupures
c'est ce qui a été fourni à la police qu
parce que une fois en cours au moment de
l'étudier cette preuve n'a pas été
divulgué il y avait vraiment un an plus
tôt je ne sais même passionnant avez
vous dit quoi que ce soit qu'on puisse
considérer comme une menace de mort
contre un drop et jack
absolument pas pourtant il existe un
enregistrement ou francisco carbonées
semble comploté pour assassiner un
groupe et jack
il a refait surface après cette entrevue
avec les frères carbonée
oui
l'enregistrement est à nouveau l'oeuvre
du criminel sacha viscères ancien fidèle
de pays jack qui semble à présent offrir
ses services de tueurs ou plus offrant
pour certains
jusque demain
dire que murakami de monex
je
comment
mais ça xavi sert à quitter le canada et
comme il est le seul témoin la preuve
contre francesco carbonées et tomber les
accusations étaient retirés
il poursuit à présent la police de
toronto aux prestations il légal
les deux frères se battent toujours pour
garder le contrôle des casinos en
république dominicaine
ils craignent encore pour leur vie de
groupe mais toujours ses activités
philanthropiques et obtient bien des
louanges les il est très inquiet des
effets que cette histoire pourrait avoir
sur sa réputation il a décliné toute
demande d'entrevue et dit regretter
sincèrement d'avoir un jour investis
dans cette aventure et que salle
embarrasse beaucoup
une bataille judiciaire je joue devant
une cour ontarienne pour savoir où sont
passés les 112 millions de dollars
prêtés aux frères carbonée
[Musique]